[Music]
if we want to turn this place right
let's just speak as one United group
who's in the UN saying no she's angry
we're all angry you don't not go wrong
mr. Caputo and we want justice
to whom it may concern even inmates of
Lichfield are human beings we are
protesting the abusive conditions under
which we are being held we're gonna give
my show I don't think it is nice do you
get this going on here we get beat for
no reason we stopped for an above like
we factory chickens we're denied basic
humanity how can I help people ain't
gonna like you starting my life
[Music]
you do what you gotta do you don't know
nothing to know what where the chance to
real hard over here y'all room you see a
problem you deal with it this is my home
and I'm a fight for we get to make
demands no idea is a bad idea
ice cream sundae bar Latin class uh
antigravity chamber we could float
around in the flips and stuff okay
some ideas are bad ideas tell this woman
what we won't want to be [ __ ]
Thank You Siri male game right
[Music]
the only way out is for us to come
together excellent idea
there's more strength in a single
unified message
[Music]
mighty spirit we are ready to receive
you
[Music]
- King
[Music]